the 50
the fifth plenary meeting of the 11th
emergency special session of the general
assembly is called to order
the assembly will continue its
consideration of agenda item 5 entitled
later data 28 february 2014 from the
permanent representative of ukraine to
the united nations address to the
president of the jail of the security
council s slash 2014-136
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
solomon islands
thank you mr president
mr president
mr secretary general
excellencies
i take the flaw to speak on this
important agenda in my national capacity
solomon islands
is following with great concern the
developments in ukraine
and deeply worried about the worsening
situation
as a peace-loving nation solomon islands
reiterated its principal position
for peaceful coexistence
non-interference
refrain from the use of threat of force
against the territorial integrity of any
state we deeply regret the intervention
into ukraine by its neighbor the russian
federation
and call for immediate de-escalation of
the situation
in that respect
we call on all to exercise maximum
restraint
put aside all provocation and restore
our faith in our rule-based
international order
as we preserve and respect ukraine's
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity
solomon islands calls on all parties
to settle international disputes by
peaceful means
we welcome talks currently taking place
between ukraine and the russian
federation
we call on all parties to listen more
and better understand each other
we trust
that this dialogue will bring a glimmer
of hope for a sustainable peaceful
outcome
we fully support efforts
made by the u.n secretary general
and call for a global unified approach
to support the talks
embracing diplomacy and dialogue
over confrontation and hostile posters
in ukraine and the region
solomon islands fed a call on all
countries to preserve the principles
spirit and purpose of the united nations
charter with open hands of friendship
and not with a clan's fist
we in the present must look to the past
as we chat our way forward
we must never forget
the united nation was created under the
assets of a world war
my people of solomon islands have lived
through what consequences a world war
can bring
never again
must the wall go through another
never again must humankind suffer its
brutal consequences
we are already inundated with global
challenges
including the covet 19 pandemic
climate change and sea level rise
as a small vulnerable state
solomon islands is deeply concerned that
the situation in ukraine
is diverting much needed attention to
our global development agenda
as we continue to combat climate change
improve the quality of all people and
deliver on the sustainable development
goals and the 2030 agenda
solomon islands stand in solidarity
with all who have lost loved ones and
expressed great concern on the worsening
humanitarian situation
we command initiatives of neighboring
states
to protect lives of the vulnerable
population
we need each other more during this
difficult period
let us use the multilateral tools
available to seek permanent peace for
the stakes are just too high if we fail
solomon islands will vote in support of
this resolution i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of the sullivan islands
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of myanmar
mr president mr secretary general
at the outset
we welcome the convening of
this emergency special session
we thank you mr president and mr
secretary general in this regard
this emergency special session is timely
and it would allow
all countries small and big to raise our
voices on the serious situation
ukraine is facing
and our concern in the state of affairs
of this universal organ the united
nations
myanmar always adheres to
and takes fan position on the
territorial
integrity independence and sovereignty
of all countries
therefore myanmar condemns the invasion
of ukraine and and provoked attacks
against the people of ukraine
these acts are flagrant violation of the
united nations charter
and international law
myanmar calls on the cause on to respect
the sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity of ukraine
we have been following with great
concern the situation on the ground in
ukraine
it is regrettable that the situation is
further escalating with intensifying
attacks of the russian russian
federation
as a result many people have been killed
and hundreds of thousands of people
left their home
the people are suffering even in the
severe cold weather
we call on immediate cessation of
hostilities and attacks on ukraine
myanmar understand and share more than
others the suffering that the people of
ukraine are encountering
the people of myanmar are facing similar
horrible suffering resulted from the
inhumane acts atrocities crimes against
humanity committed by the myanmar
military
due to the military's excessive use of
force and indiscriminate attacks on
people as well as their inhumane and
butrex
many houses religious facilities
healthcare facilities schools and
families have been destroyed
accordingly hundreds of thousands of
people have to leave their respective
places and became displaced people in
addition to number of
people dead and endure the displaced
people and victims include people from
vulnerable groups such as people with
disability elderly people women girls
and children i wish to commend the
neighboring countries of ukraine which
opened their borders and extend one
reception of ukrainians and other
nations
who escaped from the terrifying attack
we also thank all member states who
support ukraine in every possible way
i appeal them to continue to do so
and do more
mr president the u.n charter clearly
begins with
a quote we the peoples of the united
nations
determined to save succeeding
generations from the scotch of war and
code i wish to further recall that
quote we the peoples of the united
nations to unite our strength to
maintain international peace and
security and to ensure
by
the acceptance of principles and the
institutions of method that enforce
shall not be used safe in the common
interest and code excellencies dear
colleagues
it is time for all of us to stand with
justice and stand with the principle of
the u.n charter
myanmar stands in solidarity with the
people of ukraine
in doing so mnemonic sponsor the draft
resolution and will vote yes
justice
freedom
and peace
must prevail all over the world
i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of myanmar
and i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of pakistan
mr president
pakistan is committed
to the fundamental principles of the u.n
charter
self-determination of peoples
non-use or threat of use of force
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
states
and pacific settlement of disputes
equally
pakistan upholds the principle
of equal and indivisible security for
all
these principles
must be consistently
and universally respected
mr president pakistan remains deeply
concerned at the recent turn of events
this
reflects
a failure of diplomacy
prime minister imran khan
has regretted the latest situation
between russia and ukraine
and said
that pakistan hoped
that diplomacy could avert
military conflict
we have since
repeatedly stressed the need
for de-escalation
renewed negotiations
sustained dialogue
and can continuous diplomacy
all efforts must be made to avoid
further escalation of violence
and loss of life
as well as military political and
economic tensions
which can pose an unprecedented threat
to international peace and security
and global economic stability
as consistently underlined by prime
minister imran khan
the developing countries
are hit the hardest economically
by conflict anywhere
we hope
that the talks initiated between the
representatives of the russian
federation and ukraine
will succeed in bringing about a
cessation of hostilities
and normalization of the situation
a diplomatic solution
in accordance with relevant multilateral
agreements
international law and the provisions of
the u.n charter
is indispensable
pakistan also supports
all efforts to provide humanitarian
relief to civilians in the affected
areas
the government of pakistan is most
concerned
about the safety and welfare of
pakistani citizens and students in
ukraine
the majority of them have been evacuated
those who remain will be evacuated
soonest
we appreciate
the cooperation of the ukrainian
authorities
as well as the polish romanian and
hungarian governments
in this context i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of pakistan
and i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative
djibouti
mr president
mr secretary general
at the outset djibouti welcomes the
convening of this emergency special
session
of the united nations general assembly
to address an urgent
matter the unprovoked aggression against
ukraine
it is a matter of deep regret that the
security council failed to act in unison
after the veto cast by russia
thus effectively undermining the
capacity of this vital organ to exercise
his primary responsibility for the
maintenance of peace
and security
we often lament the inability of the
council to respond decisively to
emerging crisis the refusal expressed by
a majority of member states to be
paralyzed into inaction is a testament
to the commitment of member states
to ensure that the un remains relevant
in the face of vexing and complex
security challenges
djibouti unequivocally condemns what is
in our view constitutes an egregious
breach of international law and the most
fundamental principles of the united
nations charter
in particular the obligation of all
states and the article 2 of the united
nations charter to refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use of force against the territorial
integrity or political dependence of any
state
if a country has legitimate security
concerns we urge that country to
prioritize using tools as expressly
contemplated by article 33 of the
charter which obligates party to parties
to a dispute that is likely to endanger
peace and security
to seek its solution among other means
negotiation mediation
arbitration or judicial settlement
we welcome the offer of good offices
made by the secretary general and
reiterate the call by the african union
to establish an immediate ceasefire and
to open political negotiations without
the delay under the auspices of the
united nations in order to preserve the
world
from the consequences of planetary
conflict
no argument
no pretext can justify the use of force
the all-eyed war and the brutal violence
unleashed on ukraine and its people
mr president we are appalled by the
continued attacks targeting civilians
and civilian infrastructure we are
heartsick to watch the gut-wrenching
images of civilians fleeing the violence
and seeking refuge in neighboring
countries we echo the call made by the
emergency relief coordinator and the
high commissioner for refugees for
unimpeded humanitarian access so that
aid is delivered to those in need
ukrainians may have decided to valiantly
defend their country and not surrender
but if the war does not stop now they
may not survive
as a distinguished
ukrainian representative powerfully
stated if ukraine does not survive
international law will not survive
the aggression against ukraine places
and the stress the system of
international law and international
relations that the charter put into
place let us not allow decades of
efforts to strengthen the rule of law
and revitalize multilateralism
go down the drain
djibouti will therefore vote yes to
reaffirm its solidarity to the people of
ukraine
it will vote yes to uphold the u.n
charter
it will vote yes to reject the use of
armed force and any pretext in the
aggression against a sovereign country
it will vote yes in support
to the sanctity of borders
faster
towards africans and the statements by
so-called experts who are
drawing distinctions between refugees
fleeing
the conflict in the middle east and
those fleeing the conflict in ukraine
wars are the same regardless of where
they are and they always lead to the
same devastating consequences we're at a
critical moment in the history of the
united nations and we must
put an end to all conflicts and do
everything to prevent any further
conflicts it is within our reach
and we do have the resources which let
us mobilize the political will to put an
end to them thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of djibouti
and i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
bhutan
um
mr president
mr secretary general excellencies
we meet today in this august assembly
for the 11th emergency special session
of the general assembly to address the
alarming situation in ukraine a fellow
member state of our united nations
it is significant
that owing to deadlock in the u.n
security council
this is the first time in 40 years that
the provisions of the uniting for peace
resolution are being invoked
bhutan has closely observed with deep
concern
the rapidly escalating conflict on the
ground
we join others in calling for the
respect of ukraine's sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders
perched atop the himalayas even the
folds of our mighty mountains cannot
shield us from the reverberations of
events thousands of miles away
today
core principles of the un charter and a
rules-based international order are at
stake
endangering international peace and
security far beyond the borders of
ukraine and europe
mr president
each and every one of us big and small
rich and poor alike
have on admission to the united nations
ascribed to the purposes and principles
enshrined in the charter
bhutan made that solemn pledge over 50
years ago
these are principles all member states
are beholden to but for small states
they serve as the guarantor of our
existence
bhutan is a small and peace-loving
country
firmly avowed to peaceful coexistence
and good neighborly relations between
states
bhutan adds its voice to the chorus
within this hall in defense of the un
charter
in defense of the principles of
sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
of all countries
the threat or use of force and acts of
aggression against another sovereign
state can never be accepted
we cannot condone the unilateral
redrawing of international borders
bhutan will therefore support the
resolution which is now before the
assembly and in doing so
we have reaffirmed the call for the
respect of international law and the
core principles of the un charter
in closing mr president bhutan expresses
its regret at the reports of growing
numbers of casualties and loss of
innocent lives as a result of the crisis
in ukraine
our hearts and prayers go out to the
families of those who have lost their
lives in the escalating conflict and the
hundreds of thousands of others who have
been displaced and suffer in its wake
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of bhutan
and i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative
of lao people's democratic republic
mr president mr secretary general
as a peace loving nation
the lao pedia firmly upholds the
principles
of the united nations charter
and its obligation under the
international law
towards this end the lao pedia has
continued to pursue
its consistent policy
of peace independence
friendship
and cooperation with all nations
as the country previously suffered from
the scourge of war
the loud media knows too well
the endless negative consequences it
will cause to the innocent lives
we believe
what is in telling is not of the
interest to any party
the lao pedia has been closely following
the current developments in ukraine
which is complex and fragile
we commend the un
and countries
which have offered humanitarian
assistance to the affected people
mr president
we remain skeptical of the united
unilateral sanction
on the contrary
we would also be mindful that
the sanctions imposed could entail
long-term impact on innocent people
including
the global community at large
especially during the pandemic period
therefore we call all parties concerned
to refrain from any action
that could further
fuel the escalation of tension
and seek peaceful solutions and restore
peace and security
towards kissing we support the ongoing
effort
to find a peaceful settlement suited to
this situation through diplomatic beings
including the recent peaceful
negotiation held at the border of
barrows
it is important that legitimate security
concerns of all parties
be taken into account
mr president
we have heard
at this
emergency
special session
during the past two days
divergent views and opinions
nevertheless
one common
call
loudly echoed in this assembly hall
is to call for peace
which can only be achieved through
diplomatic means
it is our fervent hope that through its
this diplomatic effort
peace can be
restored peace which constitutes the
heart and soul of our organization's
united nations i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of lao people's democratic republic
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
cambodia
mr president
mr secretary general
cambodia expressed great concern
on the situation unfolding and human
suffering as well as for the loss of
life in ukraine
we strongly believe that the last
launching
lasting peace can be achieved only
through a peaceful dialogue and
negotiation all parties must ensure that
all civilian and civilian infrastructure
are protected
access to humanitarian assistance to the
people in and around ukraine must be
ensured during difficult time
cambodia fully support the successional
effort in addressing the humanitarian
crisis and to find a peaceful solution
in ukraine
on 26 february the asean foreign
minister released a statement
urging the concerned party to seek a
peaceful resolution
in accordance with
international law the principle of the
u.n charters
cambodia has its firm position that all
member state must respect
sovereignty threaten integrity and
political political independence of
other member states
with that
cambodia has co-sponsored the draft
resolution and will vote yes i thank you
mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of cambodia
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
azerbaijan
mr president
the situation in and around ukraine is a
source of extreme concern
which necessitates urgent actions
to de-escalate and find peaceful
solution
in accordance with international law
azerbaijan deeply regrets that the
ongoing crisis constitutes to cause
significant casualties
in particular
among civilian population
we express our deep condolences to the
families of those perished and wounded
we call for strict adherence
to international humanitarian law
civilian lives and civilian
infrastructures
must be protected and safeguarded at all
times
the evolving humanitarian crisis on the
ground requires expedient measures to
alleviate the impact of current
situation
on civilians
proceeding from this understanding
azerbaijan has already rendered on a
bilateral basis humanitarian assistance
of medicine and medical equipment and
other first need essentials to the
people of
ukraine this situation needs to be
settled through peaceful
diplomatic means in full compliance with
the norms and principles of
international law
guiding interstate relations including
respect for the sovereignty territorial
integrity and inviolability of borders
strict compliance with the norms and
principles of international law
concerning trend relations and
cooperation among states and the
fulfillment in good faith all the
obligations assumed by states are of the
greatest importance for the maintenance
of international and regional regional
peace and security
azerbaijan reiterates its call for
dialogue without delay to prevent the
situation from the further escalating
escalation and underlining the necessity
of direct negotiations between the
parties i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of azerbaijan
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of belarus
[Music]
share of responsibility
for what is currently happening in
ukraine
eight years ago
the minsk agreements were signed
the security council adopted
the ukrainian authorities to fulfill the
provisions of these documents
over the last eight years ukraine has
essentially found itself in a state of
civil war in as much as the kiev
authorities did not wish to sit at the
negotiation table
with their compatriots from donetsk and
lugansk
and they refused to take into account
their legitimate interests
mainly civilians the elderly women and
children
operative paragraph 8 of the draft
so there is a question then to the
sponsors and the co-sponsors of this
draft resolution
where were you
ladies and gentlemen
why over these eight years
have you not been able to urge kiev
to fulfill the provisions of these
documents
the united states canada and the eu
of course believe themselves to be the
gold standard of democracy have existed
cavalier pressure on the u.n the osce
the council of europe and the whole
international community who
they could not find the strength or
courage in themselves
to respond
to
adequately respond to the criminal
activities of the ukrainian authorities
they ask us
why are you recalling the events of the
past
lessons from the events of the second
world war the international community
then didn't
realize then that any spark of
neo-nazism in any country needs to be
swiftly
another clear demonstration of double
standards
and a confirmation of these double
standards on the side of the usa and
their allies
whose crimes have already led to
hundreds of thousands of victims
in yugoslavia in iraq libya
and afghanistan
we categorically reject
accusations against belarus that we are
involved in unlawful use of force
against ukraine
i will
let you in on a secretary yes we are
involved
the president of belarus alexander
lukashenko personally is sparing no
efforts
to
ensure contacts
between the russian and ukrainian sides
our involvement today
goes as far as organizing
negotiations
between the russian federation and
ukraine and ensuring and doing
everything we can to ensure that they
are held
we sincerely wish
every success
to the parties participants in the
negotiations
many countries in their statements
have not said a single word about these
negotiations
we understand that they
never understand they never
to the name of our country in a positive
or even in a neutral tone
negotiations to be successful
you'll be responsible
fully responsible
the position of sanctions for example
against
russian potassium fertilizers will lead
to a worsening economic and so work
assuming economic and social problems
and a growth
in hunger in your own countries and in
countries located hundreds of kilometers
from belarus
the sanctions are now not targeted
they're focused on suffocating the
economies and lowering the standard of
living of people
they're sanctions
imposed today and some people have said
that
this there is an economic war
ongoing
this is the worst example of economic
and financial terrorism
representatives of some countries
ukrainians and foreigners and citizens
of third countries to leave ukraine
on this
supposedly open border i wouldn't like
to inform you that citizens of belarus
and russia
all men over the age of 18
are facing serious problems when they
are trying to leave ukraine
ukrainian authorities are not letting
them out
and russians and better russians
are essentially
being held hostage
we also know of cases of racism and
discrimination
beatings and pushbacks across the border
of foreign citizens by polish border
guards
on the 26th of february polish border
guards beat up and turned back into
ukraine a group of around 100 indian
students
who then
were
kindly
placed in a refugee camp in romania
we're also
in minsk
receiving a lot of information both from
citizens of belarus and also from
embassies
of those countries your countries
and also to consider requests for entry
for citizens of third countries we call
on the ukrainian side to heed our cause
and open a humanitarian corridor
or even one humanitarian corridor to
leave belarus across the belarus
ukrainian border
we've already had official
contact with this request a real request
to the representatives of the un and
international
commission of the red cross in minsk
the great concern also is the rampant
abuse
and plundering including against
foreigners in ukraine
the uncontrolled distribution of weapons
has already led to a sharp spike
some of them have already died
so why are you all staying silent about
this
indeed as much as we know
at the
level of the
leadership of the african union
the price of human lives
to find a resolution to the conflict
in any way
each side
has its own truth
every war has its own dynamics
[Music]
in a sea in a flood of lies and
disinformation which is being spread
spread by
information terrorists
i can't call them anything else
the vast majority of these at the same
time are sitting comfortably in
armchairs in offices
thousands of kilometers from the
military from the
military clashes in a few minutes we
will all move to a vote on this draft
resolution
it should contain a call for an
immediate cessation of hostilities
and for negotiations to take place
i do understand that each and every one
of you have your instructions from your
capitals
i also know that some of you have been
pressured
to vote for this project
i don't have any illusions as regards
what the outcome of our vote will be
i do ask you to think once again
and vote
according to your conscience although i
understand
that
one can lose one's job at the u.n for
voting with one's conscience thank you
for your attention
i think the distinguished representative
of
belarus
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative
of the united states
mr president
mr secretary general
my fellow delegates
to all those who dedicate themselves to
the noble mission
of this institution
today we call on russia
to stop its unprovoked
unjustified
unconscionable war
we call on russia
to respect the sovereignty
and territorial integrity
of ukraine
we call on another neighbor of ukraine
belarus who you've just heard from
to stop supporting
the war and stop allowing its territory
to be used to facilitate this aggression
and today
we stand together
in holding russia accountable for its
violations of international law
and to address the horrific human rights
and humanitarian crisis
unfolding before our eyes
this is an extraordinary moment
for the first time in 40 years
the security council has convened an
emergency special session
of the general assembly
forty years
most of the men and women fighting in
ukraine were not even born the last time
the united nations came together in this
way to unite for peace
and i would venture that many of the
people in this room were not born
when that happened
but a few of the eldest ukrainians and
russians might recall a moment like this
a moment when one aggressive european
nation
invaded another without provocation to
claim the territory of its neighbor
a moment when a european dictator
declared he would return his empire to
its former glory
an invasion that caused a war so
horrific that it spurred this
organization into existence
now
at more than any other point in recent
history the united nations is being
challenged
if the united nations has any purpose
it is to prevent war it is to condemn
war
to stop war
that is our job here today
it is the job you were sent here to do
not just by your capitals
but by all of humanity
a lot has happened very quickly to bring
us to this unique moment
it was barely a week ago
when in the dead of night president
putin launched a full-scale invasion of
our fellow u.n member state
at the very moment
at the very moment the security council
was holding an urgent meeting attempting
to foster diplomacy and de-escalation
as the security council discussed peace
putin declared war
ukraine has defended itself with great
courage and vigor
as president biden said in his state of
the union address last night
president putin and i quote met a wall
of strength he never imagined
he met the ukrainian people
but the brazen and indiscriminate nature
of russia's attack has had devastating
horrific consequences for the entire
country
russia has bombed residential apartment
buildings
it has
bombs sacred burial grounds it has
shelled kindergartens and orphanages and
hospitals
russia has spurred mass hunger and
caused so many to flee their homes
the latest u.n estimate
are marching toward a million people
we thank the countries who have opened
their borders
who have opened their hearts
opened their homes to those fleeing
ukraine
and i want to echo the un refugee
agency's call to help and welcome all
those fleeing conflict without regard to
race or nationality
refugees are refugees
for those who remain
russia is destroying critical
infrastructure vital services which
provide millions of people across
ukraine with drinking water to stay
alive
gas to keep people from freezing to
death
and now it appears russia is preparing
to increase the brutality of its
campaign against ukraine
we've seen videos of russian forces
moving exceptionally lethal weaponry
into ukraine
which has no place on the battlefield
that includes cluster munitions and
vacuum bombs which are banned under the
geneva convention
we all have seen the 40-mile long lethal
convoy charging toward keith
president putin continues to escalate
putting russia's nuclear forces on high
alert threatening to invade finland and
sweden
at every step of the war
russia has portrayed the united nations
russia's actions
go against everything this body stands
for
people across the world have already
united together in exactly the way
this general assembly must do today
protests and vigils against russia's war
and in solidarity with ukraine marked
with blue and yellow have sprung up
across the globe
these are protests for peace
from bangkok to budapest from berlin to
buenos aires from sydney to seoul from
calgary to cape town and even in moscow
and minsk
people everywhere are standing up to
call for president putin to stop this
attack
the russian people are themselves
asking how many lives putin will
sacrifice for his cynical ambitions
and they are appalled
at the answer
to the russian protesters i say thank
you
thank you for your bravery
to the russian soldiers sent to the
front lines of an unjust unnecessary war
i say your leaders are lying to you do
not commit war crimes do everything you
can to put down your weapons and leave
ukraine
the truth is that this war was one man's
choice and one man alone
president putin
it was his choice
to force hundreds of thousands of people
to stuff their lives into backpacks and
flee the country
to send newborn babies into makeshift
bomb shelters
to make children and
with cancer huddle in hospital basements
interrupting their treatment essentially
sentencing them to death
those were president putin's choices
now it's time for us to make ours
the united states is choosing to stand
with the ukrainian people
we are choosing
in coordination with our allies and
partners to impose severe consequences
on russia
we are choosing to hold russia
accountable
for its actions and we will soon turn to
vote on a resolution that does just that
we believe this is a simple vote
vote yes if you believe you and member
states including your own
have a right to sovereignty and
territorial integrity
vote yes if you believe russia should be
held to account
for his actions
vote yes
if you believe in upholding the u.n
charter and everything this institution
stands for
thank you very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of the united states
was over
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
observer of the observer state of the
holy see
mr president
mr secretary general
thank
for calling this emergency special
session
as in recent days we have been shaken by
something tragic
war
the holy see joins the many member
states and millions across the globe who
call for the immediate cessation of
hostilities in ukraine
and the return to diplomacy and dialogue
mr president
the organization
has founded to save succeeding
generations from the scourge of war
and live together in peace with one
another
as good neighbors
it is the duty of all states to seek to
resolve disputes
through negotiation
mediation or by other peaceful mean
even when war has commenced
mr president
last sunday
pope francis expresses closeness with
all who now suffer as a result of the
conflict stressing that and i quote it
is urgent
to open humanitarian corridors
and those fleeing must be welcomed
with heart broken by what is happening
in ukraine
and
let us not forget the wars in other
parts of the world
i repeat
put down your weapons
those who love peace reject war as an
instrument of aggression against the
freedom of other peoples
and as a means for the settlement of
international disputes
and of course
the holy see wishes to express also in
this forum its appreciation to those
states which are offering humanitarian
assistance to those in need both in
ukraine and the neighboring countries in
which many ukrainians have sought
mr president
pope francis has called on believers and
non-believers alike to observe this
wednesday 2nd of march
as a day to be close to the suffering of
the ukrainian people
to feel that we are all brothers and
sisters
and to implore of god
the end of this world
the holy see is convinced
that there is always
time for goodwill
there is still room for negotiations
there is still a place for the exercise
of the wisdom
that can prevent the predominance of
parties and interests
safeguard the legitimate aspiration of
everyone
and spare the world from the folly and
horrors of war
may this emergency special session
advance efforts that help attain this
end
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of the holy see
i now give the floor to the observer of
the sovereign order of malta
mr president
mr secretary general distinguished
representatives
the sovereign order of malta
a sovereign entity which provides global
humanitarian aid
with a special mission to serving the
sick and the poor
as observed with great sadness and
regret
the ongoing conflict
which has impacted the lives of so many
citizens of ukraine
and which is currently created
an unprecedented flow of refugees
seeking peace and security
across their nation's borders
in eight years of conflict the order's
embassy to ukraine
has provided considerable support
advice
and material help to ukrainian citizens
and to non-ukrainian residents of the
country who are in need
the current crisis is seeing multiple
cities and towns attacked and bombed
forcing families to leave their homes
and seeking shelter elsewhere
our representatives and ambassadors in
the region report that while refugees
have sufficient means to travel and find
refuge on their own
or enjoy dual citizenship with nearby
nations the majority do not have the
resources to provide for themselves
without support
u.n agencies predict that a potential
refugee exodus of over 6 million persons
might well be the outcome of this
situation
in the meanwhile many elderly people
and those who are sick or disabled in
some way
are unable to escape the bombing and the
stress that accompanies civil and rest
our concern obviously
is for them
as much as it is for those who have
managed to live
our staff and volunteers in major
population centers within ukraine
continue to provide assistance as much
as is feasible
given the ongoing security and safety
problems
this past weekend we held a summit of
our regional ambassadors and aid
providers
under the auspices of our international
relief agency's malteser international
at that time we were able to review
both the growing extent of the refugee
crisis as well as the initiatives we are
talking to support the growing swell of
primarily mothers and children and a
small number of senior citizens
as of this morning it is estimated that
almost 700 000 individuals have made the
journey
across the borders of poland
slovakia
romania
hungary
and moldova
and each day that the conflict continues
the flow of anguished families will grow
we have seen some nations go out of
their way to welcome these individuals
and to help them through the trauma
our order of malta staff along the
border with ukraine totals over 5 000
personnel
with tens of thousands of volunteers
doing everything from serving hot food
and drink
caring for the victims of injury and
accident
providing counseling and emotional
support
and assisting in securing of short-term
accommodation
volunteers from locations away from the
border
many of them from other countries
representing churches and community
groups have driven their cars and vans
to provide transportation to new
arrivals to ensure that they are given
every opportunity to find a place to
stay
we are coordinating our activities with
international aid agencies
such as the red cross
and the unhcr
and are engaged in an international
fundraising program to ensure that
adequate resources continue to be
available for the support and
maintenance of those in need
we are encouraged that the u.n human
rights council in geneva will be holding
a debate on human rights in ukraine
today
representatives from our government will
be participating in this important
discussion
we appeal to nations of goodwill to
appreciate the trauma experienced by all
refugees in particular we appeal to
countries who are receiving refugees to
to extend the same welcome they're
offering ukrainians to those of other
national and ethnic groups who have been
caught in this conflict and who are
seeking security
the offer of help and support must cross
ethnic racial and cultural lines
and not be tainted by discriminatory
acts or attitudes
this conflict in europe drives on the
realization that the issues of
internally displaced persons and the
needs of refugees
forced from their homes
affects the whole world
africa the middle east asia latin
america
and now europe
thank you for your attention
i thank the observer of the sovereign
order of malta
for the statement
i now give the flow to the observer of
the international institute for
democracy and electoral assistance
mr president mr secretary general
excellencies
international idea strongly condemns the
unprovoked war of aggression
waged by the russian federation
with the involvement of belarus against
ukraine
a sovereign nation and a democracy
this is in bridge of international law
and international agreements and a
rules-based international order
that underpins the shared objective of
global peace
and the existence of organizations such
as international idea
the invasion order by the president of
the russian federation vladimir putin
is a blatant violation of the u.n
charter
as firm believers in the rights of
peoples who exercise their fundamental
rights and freedoms
we convey our full support to
and solidarity with the people of
ukraine
they are innocent victims of this
aggression
we salute the brave partners and
democracy activists with whom
international idea has engaged in recent
years when ukraine made huge progress
towards being a stable and thriving
democracy
we call on the international community
to spring into action to protect them
and mitigate the humanitarian
consequences of the invasion
we cannot fail to note that the military
operation was launched while the u.n
security council was meeting to discuss
the crisis
we reiterate our firm belief that
international crisis
should be addressed through the means of
multilateral diplomacy and resolved on
the basis of the principles of the
charter
it is particularly unfortunate that this
naked rejection of these principles
happens during a pandemic that has
rendered evidence the need for increased
global cooperation to make the world
governable and to achieve justice for
all
in these days we are witnessing what an
unchecked ruler for decades trampling
fundamental rights and freedoms of his
own citizens
can do to undermine peace
and democracy beyond his own borders
ukraine is a country that has
successfully reached democratic
standards over the past two decades
from respecting media freedoms to
freedom for elections
local democracy and the fights against
corruption
it is no wonder
president putin is scared of such
democratic vibrancy at his doorstep
this is a pivotal moment for democrats
all over the world to stand united in
support of ukraine
it is also the moment to reinforce
action to counter and to prevent the
rise of authoritarian regimes elsewhere
which cannot survive without kleptocracy
and the systematic violation of human
rights and freedoms
we call on russia to immediately
withdraw its military forces and fully
respect ukraine's sovereignty
revenge's interpretations of history and
attempts to change borders based on
ethno-nationalist fantasies
offer not a luminous path for humanity
but a route towards darkness and endless
cycles of violence
they certainly don't provide any hope to
the younger and unborn generations
that will bear the brunts of the climate
crisis or to the billions of vulnerable
people around the world there are yet to
realize the promise of a life free from
fear and wants and the promise of the
agenda 2030.
those are the real challenges of our age
we encourage the u.n secretary general
antonio guterres to make use of his good
offices to advance cease-fire talks
humanitarian access to the war-affected
areas and protection of civilians and
particularly the most vulnerable ones
we urge u.n member states to adopt and
enforce sanctions against the russian
federation
until withdrawal of their forces from
ukraine and the full restoration of its
territorial integrity
we urge un member states to do whatever
it takes in compliance with the
principles of the u.n charter to stop
this war and prevent any further
escalation of conflict
international idea will do its part in
collaboration with the united nations
our member states and other democratic
governments and organizations
to protect in ukraine and elsewhere
the principle that every country has a
right to freely determine its own fate
on the basis of the will of the people
freely expressed
democracies institutions and processes
are the best means to protect the right
today we must stand up for these
principles
today we must stand up for ukraine which
embodies these principles and defends
them to our greatest respect
diacu
thank you
i thank the distinguished observer of
the international institute for
democracy and electoral assistance
we have heard the last speaker in the
debate on this item
the general assembly has thus concluded
this stage of the consideration of
agenda item 5.
the assembly will resume its
consideration of agenda item 5 entitled
later date at 28 february 2014 from the
permanent representative of ukraine to
the united nations it is to the
president of the security council s
slash 2014 slash 136
to take action on a draft resolution
issued as document a slash es-11
slash
l1
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of ukraine to introduce
draft resolution a slash es-11
l1
mr president
secretary general
distinguished
delegates
we are
living through a defining moment
for
our
generation
our generation is the generation that
was supposed
by our predecessors to be saved from
scourge of war
that is why
our predecessors
created
the united nations
and yet today
it falls to us to save
future
generations
let me read the following text
our position is that
whatever grievances
a nation may have
however objectionable it finds the
status quo
aggressive warfare is an illegal means
for settling those grievances or for
altering those conditions
it may be that the nation faced
desperate problems problems that would
have
warranted
the boldest measures short of war
all other methods
persuasion
propaganda
economic competition
diplomacy
were open
to an
aggrieved country
but aggressive warfare was outlawed
the defendants
did make aggressive war
a war
in violation of treaties
they did attack and invade their
neighbors
in order to effectuate a foreign policy
which they knew could not be
accomplished by measures short of war
and that is as far as we accuse
or propose
to inquire
end of quote
in his opening statement
to the international military tribunal
on november 21
1945
in the palace of justice
at nuremberg
justice robert jackson
chief
of council
and these votes are addressed today
to mr putin
mr shoigu
mr lavrov
mr valodin
miss matvianko
and perhaps dozens more
but certainly they are not addressed
to the russian citizens
those russian citizens
who try to preser preserve their
dignity
for almost a week
ukraine is fighting fighting under the
bombs and missiles
fighting in the face of our mothers of
hardware and and countless crowds of
enemies
they have come to the ukrainian soil
not only to kill some of us not only to
shift our cause and priorities
they have come to deprive ukraine of the
very right to exist
they have come to it was happened
immediately
and the delay costed dozens of millions
of people
are we ready to pay such a price now
or is it time to demonstrate the unity
of purpose
and deeds already now
we appreciate all manifestations of such
unity and solidarity with ukraine
i would like to express gratitude to all
member states that support ukrainians in
their battle for freedom
i would also like to thank those member
states that accepted ukrainian refugees
mostly women and children
more than half a million have already
fled from russian missiles and shells
i will not recite all facts of new war
crimes and crimes against humanity that
the russian troops have committed since
my previous statement two days ago
the list is so long that it will run out
of time
the crimes are so barbaric that it is
difficult to comprehend
facing the total resistance of the
ukrainian population putin's regime has
proceeded
to widespread use of indiscriminate
weapons such as multiple rocket
launchers and aerial bombs against the
residential areas
ukrainians are being killed by russian
ballistic missiles and
thermobaric
weapons
just yesterday kiev kharkiv jitomir
mariupol melitopo and many other cities
and towns sustained heavy shellings that
killed dozens of innocents including
children
ukraine deeply regrets that a student
from india
has become a victim of this shelling by
the russian armed forces in kharkiv
we offer our deepest sympathies to india
and the relatives
of the victim
a chinese citizen was also injured
in another ukrainian city because a rush
of russia's deadly attacks
the ukrainian and foreign citizens have
become hostages of the russian armed
aggression against ukraine
in kiev russian murderers hit the city
tv tower
killing five passerbys
one of the missiles dropped on the
babin yar holocaust
memorial a sacred place
of commemoration of jews ukrainians roma
and representatives of other ethnic
groups killed by nazis during the world
war ii
what and irony
when victims of nazis are being killed
for the second time
by nazi modern followers
as the president of ukraine asked
what was the point of repeating the
slogan never again
in 80 years
it's already clear that the goal of
russia is not an occupation only
it is genocide
on 7th and 8th of march 2022 the
international court of justice will hold
public hearings in the case concerning
allegations of genocide under the
convention on the prevention and
punishment of the crime of genocide
ukraine versus russian federation
also the prosecutor of the international
criminal court has decided to proceed
with opening of a formal investigation
into the situation in ukraine
unprovoked escalation of russian
aggression
against ukraine gives reasons to believe
that crimes within the jurisdiction of
the icc continue to be committed on the
territory of ukraine
along with the situation in crimea and
donbass
recent events suggest that aggressors
troops continue to commit war crimes and
crimes against humanity
dear colleagues one might consider
observing the bloodshed in ukraine that
it is not my war
it is a mistake
the evil will never stop it requires
more and more space to conquer
if tolerated it advances further and
further
the draft resolution is one of the
building blocks to build a wall to stop
it
to stop in ukraine and not to let it go
further
the wall that will protect
all of you
in particular
younger generations
distinguished delegates
by voting today
you also reconfirm
your country's commitment
to the end charter
after the vote
i invite you ambassadors and
representatives
to stop by the indonesian lounge
and to sign this little blue
book
little part
of global magnitude
every vote in favor
of the resolution
and every signature
of country that voted in favor
would be a historical reconfirmation of
the charter it is very easy ladies and
gentlemen to sign the charter
a time of peace
it is the duty to sign and reconfirm and
implement the charter at the time of war
so stop by the indonesian lounge
put the name of your country if you
voted in favor
and after you sign this book
i will hand it over to the secretary
general
for keeping the book in his office in
front of him
so at every single moment
the secret says the secretary general
will get an inspiration
from the overwhelming majority of
nations
uan who still trust in the u.n
charter
there is a very fragile
gentleman
a very old one
he was born
in
a territory that
was part of the kingdom of hungary
he will
celebrate his
120 to 102 years birthday
in nine days
his name is benjamin
parents
benjamin ferrance was an investigator of
war crimes
a chief prosecutor
at one of the 12 subsequent trials
of nuremberg
later he became an advocate of
international rule of law
and for the establishment of the
international
criminal
court with the permission of the
producer
i would play a couple of seconds of his
votes
and i want you to listen
very carefully
three words law not war
if you can do that you save every day
billions of dollars which you can use to
deal with the legitimate complaints of
all people who need medical care
students who have to pay for their
tuition all the legitimate complaints
which could be solved if we didn't spend
the money on what was to kill them
instead of helping them and that is the
current system now how are you going to
do it
i will end by telling you how to do it
and the principle which i have guided me
that three principles one
never give up
two never give up three
i hear you never give up
good luck
i wish you the best of luck
please show respect
show respect to the charter
show respect to the secretary general
show respect to this gentleman who will
celebrate 102 years since his birthday
i call upon all responsible member
states
to support the draft
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i thank the distinguished
[Applause]
i thank the distinguished representative
of ukraine
[Applause]
we shall now proceed to consider draft
resolution a slash
es-11
slash l1 entitled aggression against
ukraine
before i open the floor for explanations
of what before the vault may i remind
delegations that explanations
of vote are limited to 10 minutes and
should be made by delegations from their
seats
i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of russian
federation
russia
[Music]
along humanitarian corridors
we also know about plans
which they have been preparing with the
participation of civilians so that
then they can accuse russia of having
carried them out
military hardware is being placed in
residential areas as well as rocket
launchers and artillery
today
we will provide examples of this to the
un leadership
still
asserting that they don't have this kind
of evidence
although videos taken by ukrainian
citizens
responsibility for this fully lies with
the ukrainian authorities much like for
the irresponsible and criminal
distribution
to weapons to anyone who wants one
including those who have been released
from prison
this has already led to many cases of
robbery murder and plundering
colleagues your refusal to support
today's draft resolutions
for a peaceful ukraine free from
radicalism and neo-nazism living in
peace with its neighbors
and refusing from to be managed from
outside
even
[Music]
this was the aim of our special military
operation who the sponsors of this
resolution try to present as aggression
we
heard from the ukrainian representative
words about nazism
radical organizations about tortured
processions
and those who support hitler
those who are interested in the
development of the ukrainian crisis and
how it was developed very much
understand where it came from
actions today we are seeing in action
today we're trying to stop the eight
year war
of the maidan regime on the people of
dunbas
the last year
majority of which are living in the lpr
and dpr we're living in the lpr and dpo
the aim of special operation is uh
announced on the basis of article 51 of
the un charter and will be achieved
however we are not
carrying out strikes on civilian
facilities and civilians don't believe
the large number of fakes spread around
the internet on this
these fakes have only
distributed like biscuits
operations of uh ukraine and this center
was destroyed
ukraine could happen if the radicals
concern about preserving civilian lives
in their country and rather than hiding
behind them
this is a call in the text before the
there was no reference to this call in
the text before us to vote on nothing is
mentioned about the illegal
coup in kiev in february 2014
with the connivance of germany france
and poland
and with the support of the united
states
where the legitimately elected president
of the country was overthrown this draft
does not mention anything along the
lines of the new nationalist authorities
are limiting the rights of citizens to
use the russian language this was a
green light for a large chain of events
violations of the basic rights of those
living in the east of the country not
only in the east of the country
including the most
valuable right that right to life
many of you
don't want to
odessa and the crimes of those who
didn't agree
europe and the us have been pumping you
at the ukraine with weapons
uh so that those people can kill
civilians
authorities
are fully ignoring the minsk agreement
and sabotaging security council
resolution 2202.
finally this draft is a clear attempt
of those who over the last decades have
committed
huge numbers of aggressions
illegal uh and international law as well
as
one of which
indeed was the maidan coup in ukraine
they present themselves as champions of
international law
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the russian federation
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
yeah serbia sincerely regrets events
taking place in the east of europe
russia and ukraine have always been
friendly country to the republic of
serbia and serbian people
perceived russians and ukrainians
as fraternal nations
we felt loss of life of which men in
ukraine is true tragedy the republic of
serbia is committed to observing
principles
of territorial integrity and political
independence of states as one of the
basic principles of international law
based on u.n charter and final act from
helsinki from 1975
which guarantees the right of states to
unviability of borders jacked just like
it is committed to preservation or
sovereignty and integrity of its own
territory
the republic of serbia likewise
advocating respect
for territorial
integrity of other sovereign nations
and regardless of not agreeing with all
formulation state in resolution will
vote in favor of resolution
i am obliged to point
to pp13 a remind to the first attack
against the sovereign state on the soil
of europe after second world war
took place not so long ago in 1999 when
19 countries attacked
at that time
federal republic of yugoslavia
primarily
republic of serbia when there was no
appropriate reaction
of such distinguished institution
to this flagrant violation of u.n
charter
despite the facts they still suffer from
consequence of sub-severe violation of
fundamental principles of international
law by others
serbia is not giving up these principles
even today
the republic of serbia will continue to
advocate
termination conflicts
expecting that the parties will invest
additional efforts
into reaching diplomatic solution and
creating condition for peace throughout
dialogue serbia will provide
all kind humanitarian aid to endangered
ukrainian citizens will remain committed
to peace and consistent respect for
international law thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of serbia
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of syrian
arab republic
thank you mr president mr president
the draft resolution
it's a means of political
pressure
those who prepared the draft resolution
incorporated an aggressive
language against the soviet
the russian federation to belittle its
legitimacy
stand
based on its
security concerns and its right to
protect its people from
the
threats
security
belarus is also
impacted
by this draft resolution this draft
resolution
represents a flagrant political
hypocrisy
had the us and its
western allies
being serious in de-escalating the
situation
they would have fulfilled the promises
they undertook three decades ago
not to expand
the eu and
transform ukraine to
into a continuous threat to the
russian federation and they should have
pressure
ukraine to abide by minsk and to stop
the violations against the civilians
let alone those countries
eagerness
to supply ukraine with heavy
weaponry and missiles
encouraging volunteers to uh fight in
ukraine
this indicates the
clear clear-cut desire of those
countries
for provocations and not for containment
and de-escalation
this draft resolution
to spread erroneous information and lies
it's not designed to
find a clear-cut and real solution for
the crisis
rather to defame the russian federation
it ignores the real
reasons for
the
escalation of tension and for the
eruption of hostilities
who
are eager to defend the charter of the
united nations
now today
they should have shown the same
eagerness
vis-a-vis israel's continued occupation
of the arab territories
and the aggression committed by the
turkish forces
against our territory what about the u.s
violations of
the territorial integrity of our land
syrian
territories
the rejection of
western hegemonistic policies and
interference in the internal affairs of
the states
prolongating
crises
promulgating and spreading
anarchy
opting for double standards
and selectivities
imposing unilateral sanctions
necessary for us to reject this draft
resolution and vote against it thank you
mr president i thank the distinguished
representative of
syrian arab republic
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of saint
vincent and the grenadines
mr president
it is clear
from the debate over the past two days
that the membership of the united
nations is united in its call to end the
war in ukraine and return to diplomacy
saint vincent and the grenadines wishes
to offer an explanation of its vote on
the draft resolution before us today
mr president
saint vincent and the grenadines will
vote in favor
of the draft resolution
we will vote in accordance with our
steadfast commitment to upholding the
purposes and principles of the united
nations charter which formed the core of
multilateralism and gave birth to our
united nations 76 years ago
it bears repeating mr president that
these principles underscore respect for
sovereignty political independence and
territorial integrity of states and
enjoin member states to refrain from the
threat or the use of force in the
conduct of their international relations
our support for the draft resolution is
rooted in our conviction
that the strict adherence to
international law including
international humanitarian and human
rights law
and the principles of peace
dialogue and compromise for the
preservation of humanity
is not
optional
as a small island developing state
full compliance with the bedrock
principles of international law remains
an existential issue
we take the floor again mr president to
repeat our call for these principles to
be applied consistently and upheld as
universal truths
instead of selective uneven and
unpredictable tools to further great
power ambition
anywhere
and by anyone
historically and in recent times we have
witnessed the naked hypocrisy
double standards and
cynical misapplication of international
law which we have condemned
today we strongly emphasize
that our
august assembly should apply the
fundamental principles of our charter
impartially irrespective of the size
economic and military power of the
principles involved
mr president
in the midst of prevailing global
challenges such as the climate crisis
and the covet 19 pandemic we simply
cannot afford another conflict
war does not manage grievances
saint vincent and the grenadines
therefore calls for an immediate
ceasefire to avert
further bloodshed
human suffering and a global catastrophe
and to engage in peaceful dialogue to
find a solution to this war
post haste
today
we must unite
for peace
thank you and peace profound to all
i thank the distinguished representative
of saint vincent and the grenadines
we have heard the last speaker in
explanations of what before the vote
before proceeding to take a decision on
draft resolution air slash
es-11
l1
i wish to address the question concern
in the majority required for the
adoption of draft resolution
in light of article 18 paragraph 2 and 3
of the chart of the united nations
is there any objection to taking action
on draft resolution a slash es-11
slash l1 by a two-thirds majority of the
membership of the
majority of the members present and
voting
i see no objection
the two thirds majority of members
present and voting is therefore required
for the adoption of draft resolution a
slash es-11
slash l1
the assembly will now take a decision on
draft resolution slash es-11
slash l1
entitled aggression against ukraine
for your information draft resolution
has closed for e-sponsorship
i now give the floor to the
representative of the secretariat
mr president i should like to announce
that since the submission of draft
resolution
and in addition to delegations listed on
the l document
the following countries have also become
the co-sponsors of a slash es 11 l11
barbados and cambodia
if any other country which the
co-sponsor a slash es11 slash l1 please
signify by pressing the microphone
button now
there is nothing further mr president
i thank the representative of the
secretariat
a recorded vote has been requested
we shall now begin the wording process
those in favor of draft resolution a
slash es-11
slash l1 please signify
those against
abstentions
the general assembly is now voting on
draft resolution
a slash es 11 slash l11 l1 entitled
aggression against ukraine
will all delegations confirm
that their votes are accurately
reflected on the screen
the voting has been completed
please lock the machine
the result of the vote is
as follows
the result
[Applause]
the result of
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the result of the vote is as follows
in favor 141
against five
abstentions
35 draft resolution a slash es-11
slash l1 is adapted
before giving the floor for explanations
of what after the vote may i remind
delegations
that explanations of vault are limited
to 10 minutes and should be made by
delegations from their seats
i give the floor to the distinguished
representative of tunisia
thank you mr president
mr president
tunisia
voted in favor of
the draft resolution in support of the
principles and values of the u.n charter
on which our
foreign policy is based
we would like to emphasize that the
crisis must be
settled by
peaceful means which is
the ideal solution to
prevent further aggravation
of the situation and further human
tragedy
the world witnessed so many
grueling wars
destructive to peace and security and
the life of people our experience
indicate that military options cannot
solve any crisis
dialogue and negotiations can
settle all differences
and finding
compromises
19 and prepare itself for a new stage
based on solidarity cooperation
and
effective engagement in multilateral
action and achieving our common agenda
we believe that the world cannot
undertake or cannot
burden itself by further crises
we encouraged the engagement
of the parties in peaceful negotiations
and we urge the international community
to intensify
efforts to
obligate these
parties to resort to negotiations in a
manner to seize
hostilities and to prepare the way for
finding permanent solutions
given the fact that international peace
and security
are a whole tunisian calls for dealing
with
all
just
questions
in one standard so that peoples can
regain their legitimate rights in
accordance with international legitimacy
to build a more stable more peaceful
world thank you mr president
to the charter of the united nations
mr president
military escalation should cease
immediately and go for peaceful
settlement of the crisis
the russian federation and ukraine
have the key to resolve this conflict
the external intervention will only
worsen the situation
mr president we fully support
international efforts to de-escalate the
war
including the efforts of the secretary
general in solving the crisis
we argue all concerned parties to
demonstrate come and seek a solution to
the conflict through dialogue
to ensure that civilians do not continue
to pay the heaviest price
a lasting solution mr president will
only be achieved through dialogue by
both parties
taking into account the concerns of both
sides
the current war does not guarantee that
it will bring peace
instead it's likely to generate
subsequent crises and human suffering
one also expresses
ladies and gentlemen of the media
the general assembly has spoken
as secretary general it is my duty to
stand by this resolution
and be guided by its call
the message of the general assembly is
loud and clear
and though still it is in ukraine now
silence the guns now
open the door to dialogue and diplomacy
now
the territory integrity and sovereignty
of ukraine
must be respected in line with u.n
charter
we don't have a moment to lose
the brutal effects of the conflict are
plain to see
but as bad as the situation is for the
people in ukraine right now
it threatens to get much much worse
the ticking clock
is a time bomb
i'm also deeply concerned with its
potential consequences for regional and
global peace and security
and the world struggling to recover from
covid
today's resolution reflects a central
truth
the world wants an end to the tremendous
human suffering in ukraine
the same truth was clear in the rapid
mobilization of funds for our
life-saving humanitarian operations in
ukraine and neighboring countries
our global flesh appeal was met with
record generosity
i'm deeply grateful to donors for their
support
with that funding in hand we'll be able
to scale up to deliver a vital medical
and health supplies food safe drinking
water shelter and
protection looking ahead
i will continue to do everything in my
power to contribute to an immediate
cessation of hostilities and urgent
negotiations for peace
people in ukraine
desperately need
peace
and people
around the world
demand it
thank you very much
foreign
submitted to this emergency special
session for vote
has not undergone full consultations
with the whole membership
nor does it take into full consideration
the history and the complexity of the
current crisis
it does not highlight the importance of
the principle of indivisible security
or the urgency of promoting political
settlement and stepping up diplomatic
efforts
these are not in line with china's
consistent position
therefore we had no choice
but to abstain in voting
mr president
the final settlement of the ukraine
crisis requires abandoning the cold war
mentality
abandoning the logic of insuring one's
own security at the expense of others
security
and abandoning the approach of seeking
regional security by expanding military
blocks
it is important to give full attention
and respect to the legitimate security
concerns of all countries and on that
basis conduct negotiations to put in
place a balanced effective and
sustainable european security mechanism
blindly exerting pressure and imposing
sanctions and creating division and
confrontation will only further
complicate the situation result in a
rapid spillover of the negative impact
of the crisis and affect even more
countries
we call on the international community
to take a responsible approach
promote the relevant parties to
immediately return to the track of
political settlement
and seek a comprehensive solution to the
ukraine issue through dialogue and
consultation
china is ready to continue its
constructive role in this regard
thank you mr president
i
thank the distinguished representative
of china i give the floor to the
distinguished representative sierra
leone
mr president
secretary general
excellencies
the delegation of sierra leone has
requested for the floor
to explain its position on the agenda
item
and vote on the resolution
the government of sierra leone is
greatly concerned
about the regrettable senior situation
created in ukraine
with ramifications for regional and
international peace and security
syrian also expresses serious concern
over the growing refugee and
humanitarian situation
in and around ukraine
and particularly the safety and
well-being of syrian students in ukraine
in appreciating efforts to provide the
necessary safety and refuge
it is important for all those fleeing
the conflict
to be treated equally
and with dignity
without discrimination
whether on the basis of race or status
a blanket denial is not the answer
no representative of the values we seek
to protect
mr president
sierra voted in favor of the resolution
based on our fundamental belief
in the sanctity of the united nations
charter
its principle
its principles
and the purposes of the organization
our vote today is not a selective
application
of our fundamental belief in the
principles of sovereign equality of all
u.n member states
the territorial integrity or political
independence of member states
non-interference
and the peaceful settlement of dispute
our vote today is not to absorb the
actions and inactions of the united
nations
particularly in addressing peace and
security questions in africa
while we believe that united nations
must be consistent in the application of
its charter
and in pursuit of its purposes
we are sorting to the threat or use of
force
and the violation of the territorial
integrity of any member state
inconsistent with the charter
must be rejected
sierra leone accordingly calls for the
full respect of the national sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
we also call for the immediate cessation
of hostilities
and in this regard we welcome the
commencement of ceasefire talks
and we urge for the continuation of the
talks in a meaningful way
finally
we also urge for good faith diplomatic
efforts to resolve the conflict i thank
you
i thank the distinguished representative
of sierra leone and now i give the floor
to the distinguished representative of
thailand
mr president
thailand has carefully considered the
draft and voted in support of the
resolution
because of the overriding importance
that thailand attaches to the principles
enshrined in the united nations charter
and those of international law in
particular
respect for sovereignty
territorial integrity
and the non-use of force against states
our support of the resolution also
underlines our deep concerns for the
plight
of affected civilians
and the humanitarian consequences of the
hostilities and violence in the area
in this regard we call on all parties to
fully comply with their obligations
under
international humanitarian law
we are also concerned with the potential
longer-term consequences
on the rules-based international order
and renew our call towards peace and for
all parties to enhance dialogue through
various means to truly realize a
peaceful settlement of the situation
thank you
i thank
the distinguished representative of
thailand and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of brazil
mr president
we recognize the exceptional
circumstances we are all facing
and we share the conviction
that the general assembly could not
remain silent
the resolution adopted this morning
conveys a message
and brazil has added its voice
to that of other members
the adoption of this resolution by the
general assembly
shows the unwavering commitment of the
international community
to upholding the core principles
upon which
the u.n is built
we are appreciative of the attention
given in different paragraphs of the
text
to the critical need to monitor and
alleviate the humanitarian situation on
the ground
we also welcome the text for urging the
parties to the conflict
to fully respect
international humanitarian law
to guarantee the safety of civilians
as well as of humanitarian and medical
personnel
and to facilitate unhindered access of
humanitarian assistance to those in need
the resolution has adopted however does
not go far enough
in underscoring that the cessation of
hostilities
is only a first step
to achieve peace
sustainable peace
needs additional steps
in this respect
it is regrettable
that the supportive role of the united
nations
that the supportive role that the united
nations can and should play
has been left by the wayside
in the eagerness to point fingers
yes the resolution is a call for peace
by the international community
but peace requires more than the silence
of guns
and the withdrawal of troops
the path to peace
requires comprehensive work on the
security concerns of the parties
the only precondition
should be an immediate ceasefire
mr president
the resolution cannot be seen as
permissive
towards the indiscriminate application
of sanctioned
sanctions and the deployment of arms
these initiatives are not conducive to
the proper resumption
of a constructive diplomatic dialogue
and risk further escalating tensions
with unpredictable consequences
to the region and beyond
we also have concerns about preamble
paragraph 15.
it is not constructive
at this moment fraught with danger
in this particular resolution
to comment on military measures
adopted by any specific nuclear power
be it the russian federation
or the members of nato
once effective negotiations do get
started
all the parties must show true
flexibility and spirit of compromise
lasting solutions
can only be achieved at the negotiating
table
through committed dialogue
brazil continues to urge all actors to
de-escalate and to renew efforts in
favor of a negotiated diplomatic
agreement between ukraine and russia
that contributes to the establishment of
the security and the stability
of the region
we stand ready to resolutely work in
favor of peace
in the discussions in this assembly
in the security council and in other
forum i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of brazil i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
united arab emirates
thank you mr president
this emergency special session comes as
the conflict in ukraine has reached a
dangerous inflection point
the international community is alarmed
by developments on the ground and this
is the clear message of today's
resounding vote
the humanitarian situation is worsening
by the day we have seen reports of
rapidly growing civilian casualties and
massive displacement the extent of which
europe has not experienced in decades
the uae is deeply concerned by these
developments
our collective responsibility must
however be towards exhausting all
efforts and using all diplomatic
channels to prevent a further
deterioration of the humanitarian
situation
we remain firm in that belief more than
ever before
yesterday the uae pledged 5 million u.s
dollars in response to the un's
humanitarian flash appeal we know that
in the days weeks and months ahead more
must be done
the credibility of this organization
born out of the ashes of world war ii
rests on its universal representation
and its effectiveness in applying the
principles that we all uphold
however as this conflict has revealed
the clear and full voice of the united
nations has only grown harder to summon
because it is not equally applied
despite deepening divisions now is time
to take a step back identify diplomatic
off-ramps and engage constructively to
end this conflict
it is also a time to summon our reserves
of wisdom and experience to guide the
way forward
global solidarity means doing more than
focusing on conflicts in some parts of
the world while ignoring others
we need to shift our mindset from
conflict management to conflict
resolution our collective security
depends on it
let this crisis be the wake up call the
future of this organization may rest on
that
we all need to galvanize un efforts to
promote the dialogue work towards an end
to the hostilities and address the
humanitarian situation for those most
desperately in need
the uae recognizes the need to meet this
moment with renewed diplomacy and
leadership
and put the needs of the people on the
ground at the center of our efforts
the avenues for dialogue must however
remain open more urgently than ever
before and we must pursue them together
mr president right now we recognize that
this resolution adopted here today is a
necessary signal of where we we need to
be going
resigning ourselves to a cycle of
perpetual violence and sanctions that
only adds to the suffering of civilians
diminishes us all
we voted for this resolution and we join
with member states in making this appeal
to peace a just peace that endures by
recognizing the legitimate concerns of
all parties and also abides by the un's
charters of principles and independence
and sovereignty and territorial
integrity
this resolution however as others have
said is not enough for a sustainable
peace resolution of this conflict
requires dialogue and effective
diplomacy
this text represents the determination
of member states to respond to the
conflict today in ukraine that is the
call that rings clearly from this
meeting
we must now turn to finding ways to
bring about its peaceful resolution with
full respect for and commitment to real
and engaged diplomacy thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the united arab emirates and now i
give the floor to the distinguished
representative of india
thank you mr president
india has been deeply concerned over the
rapidly deteriorating situation in
ukraine
and the ensuing humanitarian crisis
an indian national was tragically killed
in kharkiv yesterday due to the ongoing
hostilities
we express our deepest condolences to
his family
and to that of each and every innocent
civilian who has lost his or her life in
this conflict
we demand safe and uninterrupted passage
for all indian nationals including our
students who are still stranded in
ukraine particularly from kharkiv and
other cities in the conflict zones
many member states share this concern
we have reiterated this demand to both
the russian federation and ukraine
this remains our foremost priority
ensuring the well-being and safety of
our citizen is the basic duty of every
garment
we have therefore instituted special
flights to bring back indians home from
conflict zones
my government has deployed senior
ministers as special envoys to countries
neighboring ukraine to facilitate
evacuation
we thank all neighbouring countries of
ukraine for opening their borders and
extending all facilities to our
embassies at this time
india has already dispatched
humanitarian assistance to ukraine this
includes medicines medical equipment and
other relief material
we are sending more such tranches in the
coming days
india supports the international
community's call for an immediate
ceasefire
we also support safe humanitarian access
to conflict zones
we remain firm firm in our conviction
that differences can only be resolved
through dialogue and diplomacy
prime minister modi has unequivocally
conveyed this in his discussions with
world leaders including of the russian
federation and ukraine
he underscored the urgent imperative for
humanitarian access and movement of
stranded civilians
we therefore sincerely hope that the
second round of talks between the
russian federation and ukraine will lead
to a positive outcome
india urges that all member states
demonstrate their commitment to the
principles of the u.n charter to
international law and respect our
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
all states
keeping in view the totality of the
evolving situation india decided to
abstain and thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of india i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
resolution
of the charter
particularly the principles of good
neighborliness and
peaceful resolution of conflicts but
also the principle
for of respect for the independence and
territorial integrity of all countries
and for dialogue to resume
and use all diplomatic means necessary
to achieve peace thank you president
i thank the distinguished representative
of bahrain and now i give the floor to
the distinguished representative eritrea
thank you mr president
eritrea is taking the floor in
explanation of both after the vote on
the draft resolution a slash es
11 slash l1
eritrea firmly believes that respect for
sovereignty territorial integrity and
political independence
has enshrined in the united nations
chapter are sacrosanct
principles and should be respected by
everyone at all times
for the atonement of sustainable world
peace
eritra's vote is demonstration of his
uncompromising stand for peace
his position is against
internationalizing
incessant rhetoric
and imposition of unilateral sanctions
which regrettably further polarize
international relations
and escalate the situation with enormous
implications for civilians
instead we have consistently opted for
world regions to be given the needed
space and
solidarity to address political problems
the situation between russia and ukraine
raises serious concern with political
economic and security ramifications for
europe and the rest of the world
it requires immediate resolution by
giving more chance to diplomacy
we hope that the ongoing talks between
the two parts
on the belarusian border yields a quick
and acceptable agreement to stop the war
and pave a foundation for peace in the
region
eritrea opposes all forms of unilateral
sanctions as illegal and
counterproductive
eritrea the country that has been
subjected to such measures by the west
for two decades
including new sets of unilateral
measures understands
that sanctions do not resolve problems
of peace and security
on the contrary they only hurt innocent
people and undermine the road to peace
it will be remiss if i don't address
disturbing report that african citizens
living in ukraine
are facing difficult to cross the
borders
we call on all countries to facilitate
safe passage to people fleeing for
safety regardless of their racial
identity
let me conclude mr president by
reiterating that
that eritrea would like to see that the
windows for diplomacy remain open
we are confident of the ability of the
parties to resolve their differences
and reach an outcome
that meets the interest and concern of
all
we hope that the international community
constructively supports the parties in
their search for sustainable peace i
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of eritrea and now i give the flaw to
the distinguished representative of
islamic republic of iran
bismillah
mr president the islamic republic of
iran is following the ongoing conflict
between russia and ukraine with grave
concern
we reiterate our principled position
regarding the need for peaceful
settlement of disputes in accordance
with international law and underlined
the need for full respect by all parties
for the well-established provisions of
the united nations charter international
law including international humanitarian
law we emphasize that the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of all states
must be fully respected and the safety
and security of all civilians must be
guaranteed
in order to find long-term and
sustainable solutions to such crises it
is necessary to address their root
causes
we note that the current complexities in
the fragile region of eastern europe
have been exacerbated by the provocative
actions and decisions of the u.s and
nato the security concerns of russia
must be respected
wars and destructions inflicted on
civilian lives and infrastructures are
not acceptable
wherever they occur the islamic republic
of iran calls for urgent cessation of
facilities and the escalation of
tensions in the current conflict
in this regard iran underlines the
essentiality of dialogue to address
issues of concerns to all sides leading
to long-term results
the un must always avoid double
standards particularly when it's
considering issues related to the
maintenance of international peace and
security it is unfortunate to note that
the u.n in particular the security
council has at times neglected this
principle which has undermined its
credibility a case in point is a
security council council's handling of
the conflict in yemen mr president we
believe that the text of the resolution
before the general assembly lacks
impartiality and realistic mechanisms
for resolving the crisis through
peaceful means furthermore not all
member states of the un were given the
opportunity to engage in negotiations on
the text of the resolution
it should be emphasized that the general
assembly is not in a position to
determine the existence of an act of
aggression because in addition to
article 39 of the charity ga resolution
3314 of 14 december 1974 calls on the
security council to determine the
existence of an act of aggression
moreover convening the emergency a
special session based on the general
assembly resolution
377a shall not be considered as the end
of the dialogue
my government continues to call for a
comprehensive peaceful and sustained
resolution to the current conflict
including an immediate ceasefire and a
sort of the dialogue as well as
provision of humanitarian assistance to
the people in need for the above
mentioned reasons my delegation
abstained from voting on the resolution
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of the islamic republic of iran and now
i give the floor to the distinguished
representative
regards to the draft resolution that has
been adopted and for which we have voted
positively out of our belief in the
principles and values of international
law and the goals of the un chapter
first
finding a swift political settlement to
end this crisis through dialogue and
peaceful means and through an act of
diplomacy
should be our common goal and should
remain the goal of the whole
international community when dealing in
the current crisis
and we should also allow
to achieve this main goal
through our endeavors
egypt later it's that we should not
disregard the necessity of dealing with
the root causes of the current crisis
and
dealing with them in order to defuse the
crisis and achieve peace and stability
the exploitation of economic sanctions
outside the multilateral international
mechanisms because previous experiences
have shown that such
sanctions can have dire humanitarian
consequences and lead to uh
the to escalating the sufferings of
civilians
live up to their responsibilities and
guarantee the flow of humanitarian
assistance to all those in need without
any form of discrimination and they
should also guarantee the free movement
of the residents across the borders
because we have had reports of
discriminatory treatments in that regard
5.
egypt
warns of the economic and social
consequences of the current crisis on
the global economy
the global economy is still suffering
the
consequences of the pandemic
and
the disruption in the supply chains and
the international aviation is the best
proof
the effectiveness and credibility of the
international multilateral mechanisms in
facing the different crises and
challenges
depends
on how we deal with all the
international crisis
based on
the same standards and criteria in line
with the u.n charter and its objectives
without
[Music]
the status quo and humanitarian uh
sufferings for decades and thank you i
thank the distinguished representative
of egypt and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of algeria
thank you mr president
i would like to deliver the explanation
of vote of my country algeria
my delegation would like to emphasize
once again that algeria
is committed to the principles and the
objectives of the united nations
which should remain the basis of
international
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
the member states according to the
international legitimacy and the right
of people to self-determination
and in line with our
positions
calling for enhancing multilateralism
and safeguarding it and also in line
with our commitment to developing
amicable relationships among countries
based on peaceful coexistence and the
peaceful settlement of conflicts and the
mutual respect of international
commitments and security guarantees
my country algeria can only join
all the other efforts and diplomatic
aiming at
among nations
to safeguard international peace and
security thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of algeria and now i give the floor to
the distinction
representative of united republic of
tanzania
mr president
the united public of tanzania
has decided
to obtain this resolution
as a matter of principle and in defense
of the uh chapter
fundamentally
this decision
resulted from
our inability to amend or make
reservations to some provisions in the
resolution
we were convinced
that there was a need to adjust
the draft resolution
the united public of tanzania
believes that diplomacy is the best way
to end this conflict
to this end
we appeal to all parties to the dispute
to uphold human rights
and the obligations under international
law and humanitarian law
to de-escalate the conflict and give
peace a chance i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the united republic of tanzania and
now i give the floor to the represent
distinguished representative of south
africa
thank you mr president
and we thank you for giving us the
opportunity to take the floor
to elaborate on south africa's decision
to abstain on today's resolution
mr president let me re-terrain our
position
expressed during the discussions of the
emergency special session over the last
few days
firstly by highlighting that
south africa remains deeply concerned by
the escalation of conflict in ukraine
and the regional and international
socio-economic implications
we strongly urge all sides to uphold
international law
including humanitarian law and human
rights law
as well as the principles of the u.n
charter
including sovereignty and territorial
integrity
so president the conflict involves two
members of the united nations
in an armed conflict
which this organization has
at its foundation
the responsibility to prevent
the united nations therefore must take
decisions and actions
that will lead to a constructive outcome
conducive to the creation of sustainable
peace between the parties
the resolution that we have considered
today
does not create an environment
conducive for diplomacy
dialogue and mediation
while we agree with
and support the efforts taken by member
states
to bring to the attention of the
international community the situation in
ukraine
south africa feels that greater
attention should have been paid
to bringing the size closer to dialogue
for south africa
the text in its current form
could drive a deeper wage between the
parties
rather than contributing to a resolution
of conflict
the resolution should have welcomed the
commencement of negotiations between the
parties
additionally
the role of the security council
as well as the good offices of the u.n
secretary general could have been given
more prominence in the resolution
it is understood that one of the root
causes of conflict
is related to the security concerns of
party of the parties
this should have been addressed in the
resolution
even though this emergency special
session of the general assembly is being
held after the failure of the security
council to address the meta
we believe that the security council
should still be urged to play its role
as mandated by the charter to maintain
international peace and security
south africa believes that the u.n
especially in the context of emergency
special sessions
whose nature and significance
speak to the gravity of the issues we
bring before the international community
should be used as a platform
to build bridges
address the diversions of views
provide
and support for the parties to engage
with the spirit of compromise
while de-escalating tensions
committing to the cessation of
hostilities
and building trust and confidence
unfortunately the text before us
did not do that
south africa will have also prepared an
open and transparent process to
negotiate the resolution today
this would have allowed all of us
as equal members of the assembly
to present our views
and ideally reach a level of
understanding before the text was tabled
as member states of the organization
committed to global peace and
development
we must continue to work together to
promote peace
gestures that merely create the
impression of promoting peace
without meaningful action will not
assist
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of south africa and now i give the flaw
to the distinguished representative of
lebanon
[Music]
thank you thank you mr president
lebanon voted yes on this resolution
because
lebanon a founding member of the united
nations believes in the purposes and
principles of the united nations charter
especially the prohibition of the threat
or use of force in international
relations the principle of
non-intervention and the peaceful
settlement of disputes
mr president
these are not merely slogans for lebanon
we lived through invasions occupation
intervention in lebanon's internal
affairs and experience devastation loss
and and pain that we are still enduring
is consequences today
that's why our decision today was not
taken lightly
we know that we know what happens in
wars but we also know that wars happen
not only when people fail to prevent
them but most importantly when the
voices of war drown the cries for peace
lebanon a peace-loving nation enjoys a
good relationship and friendships with
all parties to this conflict with russia
and ukraine and in this spirit we call
on everybody to go back to the logic of
peace
mr president yesterday a european
colleague told me he has never lived
through war i was happy for him
i lived through at least two invasions a
civil war multiple assassinations and
explosions that's why mr president i
don't want anybody to live in what we
lived through it's time for the for
diplomacy for dialogue and a peaceful
resolution of this conflict i hope that
all my colleagues here in this ga hole
will put the same energy and commitment
that was put to make this vote and its
result a reality to start working for a
peaceful resolution that takes both
sides concerns and interests into
consideration so the world will step
away from this abyss of war
mr president the preamble of the united
nations charter tells us quote to unite
our strength to maintain international
peace and security now we need this
unity unity for peace the united nations
is well positioned to step up and step
in to make this peace a reality
now we need to stop the escalation in
words and deeds and help both sides to
take the path of peace for the sake not
only the two sides but for the sake of
our world mr president we in the middle
east are very concerned about this war
because of its impact on europe but also
because we know from experience what
happens in europe does not stay in
europe
that the last two world wars left deep
scars in our part of the world
obliterated countries and hopes and we
are still living its aftermath today i
hope mr president we all learn the
lessons of the last wars and i hope that
from this moment we start working only
for peace peace in our time peace and
all time as a former president the
united states said mr president i agree
with albert camus in his speech upon
receiving the nobel peace prize in
literature in 1957
that probably and as a quote every
generation sees itself as charged with
remaking the world mine however knows
that it will not remake the world but
its task is perhaps even greater for its
consists in keeping the world from
destroying itself this is the same
responsibility bestowed on us as the
charter instructed us to save succeeding
generations from the scourge of war i
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of lebanon and now i give the floor to
the distinguished representative of
malaysia
mr president
as a member of the family of nations
malaysia is committed to the principles
and purposes of the charter of united
nations and the ideals it espouses
we reiterate the inviolability of the
fundamental principles of territorial
integrity and sovereignty of a country
and peaceful settlement of disputes in
the maintenance of international
international peace and security as well
as global prosperity
all parties must uphold these
fundamental and sacrosanct principles
of the uni of the un charter and
international law that guide the conduct
friendly or friendly relations between
nations and people peaceful coexistence
many will agree that the resolution
before us is far from perfect while my
delegation continues to have concerns
with some of the language contained in
the resolution malaysia voted in favor
of it as a matter of principle and out
of our strong conviction of the
aforementioned principles
mr president malaysia values its strong
and close relation with ukraine and
russia
we believe the differences and
legitimate security concerns of both
parties given the complex
geo-political context must be addressed
through dialogue and peaceful means in
accordance with the principles of the
u.n charter and rule of law
in this context we welcome the direct
talks between help between russia and
ukraine in belarus and urged both sides
to continue on the peaceful path to
prevent further loss of life and
destruction
from the vivid discussion at this
emergency special session what stood out
glaringly to us as an overwhelming
desire was an overwhelming desire for
the current conflict to be peacefully
resolved the general assembly has spoken
with a clear and fervent voice on the
matter today
now more than ever the security council
has to live up to its primary
responsibility
as the as the custodian of international
peace and security malaysia calls on the
security council to spare no effort in
resolving this conflict mr president the
future of humanity is at a precipice
humanity must prevail and peace is the
only answer thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of malaysia now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of nepal
mr president
mr secretary general
my delegation is distressed by the
ongoing violence and conflict in ukraine
conflict anywhere
inflicts stress everywhere
nepal is a peace-loving country
as its soil is consecrated
by the birth of lord buddha
an apostle of peace
for us
values of peace
harmony
and peaceful coexistence
are our way of life
so
they are supremely precious
norms of world peace
respect for sovereignty
territorial integrity
and non-aggression as enshrined in the
u.n charter
are the fundamentals of our foreign
policy
the use of force against ukraine
goes contrary to these values and
principles
nepal opposes this violation of
international law
and the principles of human charter
mr president
there is no alternative to diplomacy and
dialogue to building peace and
sustaining it
nepal welcomes
the second round of talk between russia
and ukraine
we urge both sides to continue the
dialogue with utmost sincerity and
integrity to resolve this conflict
peacefully
and find a lasting political solution
for their enduring peace and peace for
the europe
based on nepal's principled position on
the inviolability of sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
independence of any state
on the international law
rules-based international order
and united nations charter
my delegation has voted yes
on the draft resolution that was before
us today i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of nepal and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of iraq
thank you mr president
we have requested the floor to justify
our vote
abstained
in this vote
on resolution a slash es-11
slash l1
yes
iraq regrets the deterioration of the
situation and the escalating tensions
between the russian federation and
ukraine
and iraq calls upon all parties to
settle this conflict by giving priority
to dialogue and through the diplomatic
means
and we
invite them to go back to negotiations
in order to solve their
concerns
and in order to safeguard international
peace and security
threaten the world with economic and
political crisis resulting from this
situation
iraq expresses its grave concern
over the possibility for the terrorists
of exploiting this crisis and the
expected division in the international
this would hinder the international
efforts
and our joint endeavors aiming at
preventing terrorism and violent
extremism
and because of our
sufferings
resulting from the continuing wars
against our peoples
iraq
and in principle
does not support wars as
and we reiterate that all conflicts
should be settled peacefully in order to
safeguard the lives of civilians
[Music]
the security and safety of the
international staff and the humanitarian
workers and thank you i thank the
distinguished representative of iraq and
now i give the floor to the
representative of jordan
[Music]
jordan has voted for the draft
resolution that has been adopted in
order
to emphasize
the sovereignty of states and their
territorial integrity and political
independence and because we believe that
force should not be used in
international relations because it goes
against the provisions of international
law and the un charter
jordan
hopes that we will be de-escalating
tensions in order to reach a peaceful
settlement of this conflict and that
both parties will sit together on the
negotiation table in order to reach such
a peaceful settlement we also hope that
international efforts will be
intensified on both the political and
diplomatic levels to assist the parties
to end this crisis
and in order to
avoid
the dire consequences that have risen
and could arise out of this conflict
and we would like
to reiterate that all parties
and i insist all parties should
respect the international humanitarian
law human rights and the international
refuge law without any discrimination
would like to remind of the necessity of
respecting the international law
provisions and the u.n charter whereas
use should not be a force should not be
used against other countries and peoples
and should not be used against the right
to self-determination and that a single
standard should be implemented
regardless of the region concerned and
without any discrimination in
implementing international criteria and
standards
and we hope that this would lead to an
effective dialogue inside the
organization
in order to implement this approach
and to assess the current approach
and to reach our common goal thank you
mr president i thank the distinguished
representative jordan we have heard the
last speaker in explanations of walt
after the vote we will now hear
statements after the adoption of the
resolution and now i give the floor to
the distinguished representative of the
european union
mr president
mr secretary general dear colleagues
last week the un security council was
prevented to act against russia's
unprovoked and unjustified military
aggression on ukraine
because of one
isolated vote that of the russian
federation
immediately after that we initiated work
to ensure that this body
where the countries of the world can all
speak up
lives up to its responsibility
over the past few days the european
union has worked hand-in-hand with
ukraine and countries from all parts of
the world to prepare the resolution just
adopted we thank all countries that have
supported it the decision is clear
the world has spoken
the russian government must immediately
stop the aggression withdraw its troops
and abide by the rules of the u.n
charter that applies to all
equally
over the past days the brutality of
russia's invasion with the complicity of
belarus
has reached unimaginable levels
with indiscriminate attacks against
ukrainian cities causing death and its
destruction among civilians in complete
disregard of international law
distinguished colleagues and friends
this is not just about ukraine
this is not just about europe this is
about defending an international order
based on rules we have all signed up to
the sovereign equality of all states
large and small
this is about whether we choose tanks
and missiles or dialogue and diplomacy
today's historic vote clearly shows
russia's isolation from the rest of the
international community
by voting overwhelmingly in favor of the
resolution we have chosen to defend
peace where russia has chosen brutal
aggression
we have chosen to defend this
organization and its charter where
russia has violated the fundamentals of
both
russia stands increasingly alone the
european union and the world stand with
the ukrainian people thank you very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of
the european union and now i give the
floor to the distinguished
representative of denmark on behalf of
the nordic and baltic countries
mr president i have the honor to speak
on behalf of the eight nordic baltic
countries estonia finland iceland
latvia lithuania norway sweden and my
own country denmark
mr president from all corners of the
world we have come together to send a
resounding yes
to uphold international law and the u.n
charter
a resounding years to the principle of
the sovereign equality of all u.n member
states
a resounding years to the need to
respect the territorial integrity
sovereignty and political independence
of all u.n member states
a resounding message to ukraine and all
ukrainians in the words of a colleague
who spoke yesterday
you are not alone
we stand with you today tomorrow and
until peace prevails and ukrainian
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity are fully restored and
respected
we have also sent a clear message to
russia and to belarus stop the
aggression now full stop
what you are doing is unacceptable it is
wrong
your unprovoked aggression against
ukraine is a violation of the core
principles that you signed up to when
you laid the foundation of this very
organization of this community of
nations
your invasion of ukraine deserves our
strongest condemnation
you will be held accountable and every
legal avenue available must and will be
used to hold the aggressor to account
you must stop the war immediately you
must return your troops to russia
you must return to the path of peace of
genuine dialogue
it is not too late to stop it is not too
late to reverse the course
it is not too late for you to return to
this community where we believe
with all our faults and imperfections in
the principle of the sovereign equality
of old
mr president we are deeply concerned by
the grave unfolding humanitarian crisis
we demand that all parties fully comply
with their obligations under
international humanitarian law and human
rights law
protect civilians and critical civilian
infrastructure and ensure the safe rapid
and unhindered humanitarian access and
passage
humanitarian and medical personnel as
well as hospitals and other medical
facilities must be protected
mr president
thousands of civilians have been killed
more have been injured and close to a
million innocent civilians have been
forced to flee across borders even more
have been internally displaced inside
ukraine
they are in need of help and assistance
without delay without hindrance and
preconditions and we take this
opportunity to salute and express our
deepest respect appreciation and
admiration for the generous assistance
and protection that ukraine's neighbours
have shown to all those fleeing the
conflict men women and children from all
corners of the world
once again we include by echoing the
words of a peaceful protester who had
written on her sign
if russia stops fighting there will be
no more war
if ukrainians stop fighting there will
be no more ukraine i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of denmark
so
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of turkey
thank you mr president
we thank you for conveying this historic
emergency special session of the general
assembly session that was called because
the security council failed once again
to fulfill its primary responsibility
a session that was convened due to the
unjustified illegal and illegitimate act
of aggression against the founding
member of the united nations by a
permanent member of the very organ
entrusted by the entire membership with
preserving peace and security
session that was held as a result of the
use of veto power by the very member
that's perpetrating the aggression mr
president we are obliged to reiterate
russia's ongoing military offensive
against ukraine blatantly violates the
fundamental rules of international law
and the principles from which this
august organization was founded rules
and principles that aim to prevent wars
and protect mankind from disastrous
consequences
consequences that we are unfortunately
witnessing in and around ukraine due to
russia's attacks
the international community could not
have been a spectators to such an act of
aggression i am proud that as of today
it is not with today's resolution the
united nations emphasizes loud and clear
that it stands against egregious
violations of
the independence sovereignty territorial
integrity and political unity of fellow
member states the membership is
committed to preserving the latter and
spread of the fundamental constitutional
document of our organization the charter
by adopting this resolution the most
democratic institution of the multiple
system announces in the strongest
possible terms russia's aggression
against ukraine we applaud the member
states to contribute to the collective
endeavor that culminated in today's
outcome
you have stood firm in upholding full
respect for the un charter and
preserving the rules-based international
order
we hope and trust that the cause and
demands in this historic resolution will
not fall on deaf ears this body must
follow true with its decision
once again we call on russia to hear the
demands of the global community and heat
its own people's pleas to
stop its military operations withdraw
all its forces from ukraine reverse its
decision regarding the areas of donesk
and luann's creations of ukraine and its
annexation of crimea and return to
diplomacy and dialogue without delay we
also reiterate our call for an immediate
humanitarian pose
the peoples of the world hold their
breath and wait with hope to see the
march to the precipice halt
it is still not too late to go back to
the negotiating table with serious
engagement mr president as a neighbor
and friend of both the russian and the
ukrainian people turkey stands ready to
facilitate the peaceful settlement of
the conflict thank you mr president i
thank the distinguished representative
turkey
we still have nine more countries
who wish to member states who wish to
speak
therefore we have heard the last speaker
in statements after adoption
for this meeting we shall hear the
remaining speakers this afternoon in
this all at 3 pm the meeting is
adjourned